je ne suis ni noir ni blanche mais
différente dit d'emblée nikirelli dans
sa vidéo de campagne où elle se dit
fière de ses origines indiennes à
bamburg sa ville natale en Caroline du
Sud le chemin de fer séparait la
population blanche des Afro-Américains
elle dit être bénie d'être né et d'avoir
grandi aux États-Unis à 51 ans Nicky
Ellie plonge donc pour obtenir
l'investiture républicaine et devient la
première rivale officielle de Donald
Trump
et le gouverneur de la Caroline du Sud
en 2010 elle se fait remarquer en 2015
lorsqu'elle ordonne de retirer le
drapeau confédéré du Capitole de l'État
peu de temps avant un suprémaciste Blanc
avait tué neuf à froid américain dans
une église à Charles Stone
je tiens tête aux intimidateurs
je donne des coups de pieds avec des
talons hauts et ça fait plus mal
à aucun moment elle ne mentionne
l'ancien président Donald Trump qu'il
avait à l'époque nommé ambassadrice aux
Nations Unies
internationale on lui connaît alors un
certain franc-parler
vous ne pouvez pas mettre du rouge à
lèvres à un cochon disait-elle alors que
les États-Unis se retiraient de l'accord
sur le nucléaire avec l'Iran
elle soutient aussi le déménagement de
l'ambassade américaine à Jérusalem et
affirme au pays qui s'y oppose que les
États-Unis s'en souviendront
elle quitte les Nations Unies en 2018
sans éclat et reste en bons termes avec
burn off chambre
à tel point qu'elle s'engage à ne pas
briguer l'investiture républicaine en
2024 ah ouais
je ne vais pas me lancer dans la course
des Étel si dans notre chambre se
présente
aujourd'hui elle se défend en affirmant
que le parti a besoin d'une nouvelle
génération de dirigeants elle récolte
pour l'instant que 5% des intentions de
vote
devancer de loin par le gouverneur de la
Floride De Santis qui ne sait pas encore
lancé et dans notre chambre
la compétition nous rend meilleure 17
élus républicain
je l'aime bien lancer au passage le
sénateur côneur plusieurs candidats
républicains risquent de se présenter
avant les primaires dans un an Nick et
Élie répète qu'elle n'a jamais perdu une
seule élection et qu'elle n'est pas
prête de commencer elle débute sa
campagne en Caroline du Sud avant de se
rendre dans l'AUA et au New Hampshire
ici Radio-Canada Washington